Vâm mu hàng đề mắt cóp với gái, năm 2008, sau ba giờ gian.
Hà văn tí và mười tuổi bị công an bắt giữ về hành vi bắt cóp trẻ em.
Chiyor mũn thống bẩy, tí dừng xe máy tại bản kẻ, sáng gọc chiến,
Vâm mu hàng của nhóm trẻ bán dừa phen đường,
lời dụng xe ở tí bắt cóp 1 bẻ gái sấu tuổi, rồi bò trạc theo hướng sang tình lào gái.
Vân bắt giữa sau tí bị công an bắt giữ khi đang lần chúng tại sã trạm tấu lào gái,
các hiện chương khoảng 60km.
Vân bắt cóp 1 tí mỗi, tí mỗi, tí mỗi, tí mỗi, tí mỗi.
Bây giờ người tinh xe trởi bắt cóp 2 tí mỗi, tí mỗi tí lấy.
Bây giờ người tinh xe, tí mỗi, tí mỗi, tí mỗi, tí mỗi tí mỗi.
Bây giờ người tinh, người tinh xe, người tinh mỗi, tí mỗi.
Đây cai được dải thủ ăn toàn xe khỏe, đứng, bu vies đàn phép tuổi được làm dò.